he's the number seven middleweight in
the world he has a big old fight coming
up he rode his Harley-Davidson from
Orange County all the way to calabas
California to come on down here it's
John Strickland on this week's food
truck Diaries and I'm feeding them
Mexican bowls let's go
[Music]
[Music]
I need everything I get super thick boy
[Music]
came in finally you're here my man Joe
Rogan Junior what's up man little little
taller a little more handsome a little
less little less reddish famous
like the best thing no nowhere near as
rich not even close you came in on the
hog huh yeah man [ __ ] traffic dude
[ __ ] traffic's brutal out here now
you're probably the toughest guy here
because you came you're not gonna see
too many motorcycles around here with
the motorcycle though aren't you because
you've had an accent before yeah and
you're out two years dude I just want
traffic honestly [ __ ] I was splitting
Lanes like 120 last night and I was like
I shouldn't do this but [ __ ] this
traffic so my question for you is uh
obviously your manager works with Izzy
too you guys have to fight each other I
mean I gotta fight a big scary black man
you got you gotta get through there yeah
he's a bad man I'm not Izzy I'm not
gonna run around with my [ __ ] twinkle
toes and you know around like a little
[ __ ] you're gonna go forward on them
I'm gonna try you're gonna do your thing
yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] try did you uh
you know coming off the last fight with
Pierre I I had you beat it I thought you
were gonna beep here me and your Majors
were talking about this before I thought
nine times out of ten I think it's a
good fight for you just [ __ ] happens
yeah especially at this level you know
man
how if it was five rounds I'd be a
little bit more patient yeah it's one of
those [ __ ] up things where I [ __ ] you
guys not [ __ ] you're not
right before I go off I tell my my coach
I'm like I'm gonna be like two and a
half minutes in I'm Gonna Fill this
[ __ ] out and then I'm gonna
shoot on him two and a half minutes and
I get caught so you know fighting here
he's a big [ __ ] scare Brazilians
talented grew up in [ __ ] poverty he's
a mean [ __ ] you know he's a bad
[ __ ] yeah clipped is what it is
yep on to the next yeah but then on to
the next the good thing is you beat
Jared Cannon air you're right back in
the title shot so it's not like you
jumped all the way back in the queue
like The Narrative of view versus Izzy's
a pretty damn I know I actually slid
into Jared's DMs I asked him if he let
me win but I don't know what'd he say
they responded on the fence with it you
know I said I'd give him half my purse
so he's a that's not bad gig yeah is
that legal I don't know I yeah I don't
know that's all right he didn't respond
look at Jeremiah versus Kevin Holland
dude we all blimp we're blurring the
lines of what's legal these [ __ ] days
dude again let me take the heat for that
[ __ ] because I thought it was suspect I
thought the UFC 279 was suspect I got a
lot of heat for that and even I wasn't
like I'm not sold on this being a fixed
job here I'm just saying a little it's a
little too convenient for me everyone's
like this is ridiculous how dare you it
happened very [ __ ] weird
you know here's the thing about your
mind if he's you she's Golden Boy they
love the chimaya if you know everybody
needs some of in their lives especially
Dana White yeah yeah so I mean you and
you think you I heard you uh you're in a
previous interview you were saying
shamaya would probably be better maybe
he should be at 70 he'll be champ at 70
but 85. so if it wasn't for my accident
I would still be 70 and I'd be better at
70 but you know I had to go [ __ ] hit
a truck or a van so that kind of put a
cramp in my style
but your life is better than 85 I mean
I'm fighting in eight weeks here we're
about to eat a [ __ ] food truck you
know I don't know I think it's it's like
gluten-free it's healthy saying you
ain't [ __ ] healthy uh no they up they
have fries yeah so you know yeah a 70
would be better for him but the 85 dude
kind of takes us the 70 takes a soul
from you a little bit Yeah so he'll be
happier at 85 and you know he'll be fine
85. and you like him at 85 like you take
you like take a he shot him he's a he's
a big [ __ ] you know he should be
funny scary dude yeah he's a big
[ __ ] he should be [ __ ] I don't
really think um I don't really think
that you know he's gonna have an issue
in 85. no not I he's a bit have you
obviously you've seen him in person yeah
we train a lot he's a solid dude oh
you've trained with him yeah he's a good
dude he's a good [ __ ] dude and how's
it Go training
oh [ __ ] a man he he like everybody to
him is a [ __ ] there's a video of me
like asking him to go light on people
and everybody to him dude is a [ __ ]
punching bag
you could be like shamaya this guy is
like three fights dude he's new he's
like he's a [ __ ] 55 or don't hurt him
and she might have like I understand I
understand and actually not your mind's
on top and beating the [ __ ] out of it
but I mean he but you here's the thing
though you like training with that
intensity I respect that like if I go to
someone if I go to someone's gym and
unless a coach says hey be nice to this
[ __ ] like I'm not gonna be nice
to your team I'm gonna try to knock them
all out why the [ __ ] not that's what we
cross train but but the word on the
street is you go pretty hard too I mean
you're respectful but you go hard too it
depends man I mean it depends like you
know [ __ ]
the thing about fighting dude these days
there's a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ]
especially Americans and Americans are
the biggest [ __ ] [ __ ] how so like I
mean how many current American Champs
are there correct like you know you look
at this badass [ __ ] Brazilian just
knocked me out like bro it's like
Americans are soft as [ __ ] dude too much
[ __ ] Starbucks life is [ __ ] too
good for you [ __ ] too
comfortable I'm almost like I'm almost
I'm almost hoping Russia [ __ ] nukes
us just so our [ __ ] nuts get a little
bigger dude you guys are too soft we're
too soft yeah [ __ ] beta males they're
[ __ ] man buns and [ __ ] those are
probably a couple man buns behind me let
me see yeah there's less people one man
bun I mean but they all could have
[ __ ] man buns we could have some so
you think you're like the last yeah and
I'm the last white trap I'm the 90s bro
Patrick [ __ ] Swayze ride motorcycles
dude [ __ ] hot women so you don't so you
don't see a lot of Americans well it's
also there's this big surge of
dagestanians and Russians they come up
doing it yeah well it's not they come
you know because they're hard [ __ ]
men you could take you could take MMA
fighters is their kids and they're still
[ __ ] [ __ ] to the Americans like my
main training Partners not a lot of them
are Americans if I do train the
Americans or usually like D1 wrestlers
they're like they have grips kids are
tough like Bo nickel you and Bo Nick are
like the two Americans doing the damn
thing yeah yeah but most Americans you
guys are [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't know
what happened to you guys maybe the
plastic in the water [ __ ] I don't
know I'm sure Joe Rogan Knows Why let's
ask this [ __ ] he might know yeah
that's the guy that gets me famous I
could write a [ __ ] book deal after
going Joe Rogan maybe it was [ __ ]
yeah it's different you're a good
comedian bro look I'm funny too
we get our press conferences man oh
that's why I'm [ __ ] here I can't
fight but I can make you [ __ ] [ __ ]
loud you can fight don't tell yourself
short and especially if you beat Jared
Canon there then you're fighting for a
title shot
time will tell but yeah anyways back to
my rant about Americans you guys are
just soft [ __ ] you got to get
hit by your family more we need to bring
back alcoholism maybe some drug abuse be
good for you guys just toughen them up
yeah yeah look at me look at like you
grew up tough yeah you have that
perspective I mean you know you [ __ ]
Dodge a couple beer bottles and you're a
[ __ ] kid you like you you hard enough
I'm not saying that the world will be
better a better place than or me but you
guys need to get hit by your dads a
little bit more not even here not like
not discipline you guys don't need to be
like I didn't take out the trash hit you
guys need to get like an alcoholic rage
beating and then you'll start [ __ ]
learning how to have you know nuts yeah
I don't know some of the experts might
have some questions about that but you
seem to know what you're doing yeah we
all know dude like we all [ __ ] know
like I was a product in 90s like who did
you guys like action heroes of the of
the 220 2022 who do you guys got who do
these kids have to look up to
Chris Pratt yeah The Rock The Rock [ __ ]
The Rock's a [ __ ] beta mail dude
everybody loves a rock why because the
rock doesn't pissing anybody off we had
[ __ ] Patrick Swayze [ __ ] the
Terminator before he starts [ __ ] his
maid we had we had special Sloane but we
had good people they would ride
motorcycles they like guns they would
[ __ ] hot women they would fight people
with Jean-Claude Van Damme yeah that's
what I'm saying now we got the [ __ ]
rock dude Chuck Norris and again I like
the Rock The Rock's a likable [ __ ]
guy but that guy's a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
this is who your kids are looking up to
some yes to this Sean who who's who's
tough in your eyes then
in today's world
that's not that's what I'm trying to
tell you guys like you're done here's
the thing dude like Roadhouse I was
thinking about this other day you guys
all seen [ __ ] Roadhouse Patrick
Swayze yeah they're redoing it your boy
Connor's in it but they were thinking
about casting what Ronda Rousey at one
point did they joke about that she was
cast as she was supposed to do it yeah
[ __ ] Ronda Rousey guys how do you put
Ronda Rousey in the same category as
Patrick Swayze Ronda Rousey's a soft
soft woman his thing you know what Ronda
Rousey do to Patrick Swayze if they
fought though
I don't know about that dude I would
[ __ ] around the Rousey but both hand
side behind my back yeah I've never hit
a woman
well at least not unconsensually but but
you're the number seventh middleweight
in the world Patrick Swayze bottom line
is here here's the thing you guys
women are very strong they're very
amazing I love them but women are weak
you know women are [ __ ] weak my
manager Tim he's like this big jerks off
Izzy for a living and you know he could
probably [ __ ] up Ronda Rousey oh man I
don't know not like that dude if you
watch Gengar Musashi wrestle with Ronda
Rousey it's like him playing with a
little [ __ ] puppy like you know like
[ __ ] me what is Ronda Rousey gonna
[ __ ] do like his entire movie about
her trying to get Tampax in the [ __ ]
men's restroom like what the [ __ ] are we
doing I didn't read the script yeah [ __ ]
dude I'm moving on no let me feed you
let me feed you so yeah you get too
fired up let me feed you so you don't
get too fired up
[Music]
thank you
I'll do the uh asada Rice Bowl okay I
get a side of shrimp on there too
whatever this gentleman's having
yeah I'll do the uh Heritage Bowl
all right I'll do it thanks
yeah this looks good man thank you
appreciate you
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up Fam thank you guys for
watching let's take a little break from
chatting with the very unique Sean
Strickland because guess what fall is
here and that means it's time to shave
down that bush you're working with
fellas that's right the leaves are
falling it's time that bush takes the
Fallen as well maybe getting your
pumpkin spice latte and you're like man
this bush is getting out of control it's
like Jumanji down there my Levi's I
gotta figure this out well my friends at
manscape got you covered that's right
they got you covered man join the Six
Million Bros worldwide who trusts
manscape by going to manscape.com for 20
off and free shipping with the code
shop20 for the best male grooming
products on the freaking planet Earth
alright whether you're brand new or
already with the team at manscape you
could use the crown jewel of care for
your family jewels I'm talking about
that Platinum package 4.0 if you watch
this show before you've watched a fight
campaign and you know we ride with
manscape you know a little something
about the Platinum package 4.0 but if
you don't you're new and just tuning in
because you're Sean Strickland fan well
I'm glad you came welcome welcome to the
thick Squad and what we do is we take
care of our under Parts our
undercarriage it's firing up down there
but the one thing we don't have here is
a bush because we use the Platinum
package 4.0 in this package what do you
get Brendan glad you asked what do you
get you get the lawnmower 4.0 body
trimmer the weed whacker nose air here
trimmer all right then you also get the
whole body wash Ultra Premium two in one
shampoo and conditioner plus you get the
Ultra Premium deodorant and the crop
preserver ball deodorant and crop
reviver to make sure your balls are
smelling real tasty for your friends
down there all right you also get a
little shed travel bags you can put
everything in there they're giving you a
free gift that's right you get a free
gift you get the boxers as well and a
shed travel bag to put all your goodies
into it so go to manscape.com get 20 off
and free shipping with Coach shop20
that's schab20 that's 20 off and free
shipping at manscape.com when you use
the code shop20 manscape clear out the
leaves it's your tree trunks time to
shine now let's get back to the program
I'm a man let's dig in looks pretty good
balls aren't sweating anymore uh it's
it's hot in the valley man I hope you
don't [ __ ] your pants and run your
motorcycle after eating this yeah no
it's good man that's good
so I'm out of that hungry but not to not
to break the [ __ ] fourth wall we're
supposed to eat right this is the
[ __ ] podcast no you don't have to eat
oh and I could just stare at it you
don't have to do anything really [ __ ]
good you got a fight coming up you don't
have to I'll eat yours when you leave
that's how this works dude I'm living
off coffee today black coffee no [ __ ] no
I kidding me I'm not a [ __ ] you're
not a Savage
that old friend
[ __ ] sugar dude I thought for sure
Patrick Swayze drinks it black for God's
sake Patrick's also [ __ ] dead you
know this is a fair point man died of
cancer you drink black coffee drink some
cream and sugar be [ __ ] happy that
might do it dude nah dude your life is
[ __ ] miserable enough do you enjoy
your cream and sugar diet [ __ ]
diabetes be [ __ ] happy eat some
[ __ ] gluten be a [ __ ] happy guy
why not yeah that's a good message yeah
but it's nice being in this [ __ ]
Studio
it's so hard it's [ __ ] nice here you
guys should see it man it's not thanks
brother one of your uh your buddies
slipped the beans that used to date
Ronda Rousey that little hot second ago
how was that dude how was that you
married you got a girlfriend I have a
wife two kids my man oh [ __ ] so we won't
go how was Ronda Rousey school she was a
I'll tell you what I've been around a
Savage are we talking about a Savage are
we I'm telling you Bubba I'm telling you
I don't know what women have in your gym
her when she was coming up Savage my man
I've seen her beat up dudes let me tell
you why I hate Ronda Rousey guys I'd
love to hear it do you know her at all
have you ever met her never met her I'm
sure she's really sweet take that with a
grain of salt she did like a really hot
like uh Sports Illustrated one she had
like almost a nipple showing I'm sure
you love that but or you didn't care but
let me tell you I hate Ronda Rousey
so Ronda Rousey goes on Ellen DeGeneres
you know who is a known [ __ ] by the way
just Sinclair and she says after her
loss she thought about committing
suicide and after that after the Holly
Holm plus yeah yeah and after that I was
like you are the weakest [ __ ] human
being I have ever met or ever ever heard
speak after that I hated her like mental
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I can see from your perspective how you
can think that I think for her she's
playing were you with her during the
time or no no uh when she lost no way
before that so I think for her there's
so much expectations on her mom if you
know how she grew up yeah and her dad
like killed himself too but here's the
thing dude so it's in right it's in her
face here's the thing dude and this is
my y'all also before you go on let's
talk about the most famous person UFC at
the time oh yeah no I'll tell you right
now but you're worth multi-millions
multi and I mean this is this is why you
you have personal Insight you are one of
the most famous people people love you
people want to [ __ ] you they want to
marry you I mean you probably at the
time to two no offense but like people
love
people love this [ __ ] woman there's
kids right now they would [ __ ] cut
off their hand for one more day to live
we're going through chemo and you go on
an Ellen's show after all your money and
you cry you talk about [ __ ] suicide
like you are the weakest [ __ ]
like if you haven't if you haven't had a
gun or a knife to your body at some
point like you probably aren't even my
[ __ ] friend but like she wasn't
contemplating suicide she was [ __ ]
depressive and after she did that
interviewed I just it ruined everything
about her her to me it's like I can see
how you think that and kids these days
you're listening everything with [ __ ]
kids these [ __ ] days like since when
did suicide become [ __ ] cool like and
you guys it's an easy way out no it
became [ __ ] cool they made some
stupid [ __ ] Netflix show what 13
Reasons oh yeah I didn't watch that dude
like when I was a kid no one talked
really about suicide it wasn't fouled
are you uh 31 yeah yeah like it wasn't
[ __ ] cool it wasn't an option yeah
and now you take these kids these days
and every [ __ ] kid has to have some
like persecution let me tell you why
like let me tell you why at this one
point in my life I was depressed I
contemplated suicide no you're a [ __ ]
snowflake you've watched too much
[ __ ] TV and like with Ronald and
social media and that was with Ronda
Rousey it's like she needed some sort of
like let me tell you why
let me tell you why like I'm a victim
like no you're not a [ __ ] victim oh
you can see how you think that but one
thing you should know is Rhonda does
suffer from mental illness we all
[ __ ] suffer from Mental Illness but
we do you don't suffer mental illness I
don't you don't never want your
depression you've never gone to play
suicide never no [ __ ] maybe he's a
[ __ ] sociopath dude maybe nobody
nobody nobody in this [ __ ] room is
contemplated suicide at one point in
life nobody in this [ __ ] room [ __ ]
red shirt guy he did every [ __ ]
at some point not every [ __ ] but
a lot of us have laid in bed and thought
to ourselves like man I'm really sick of
this [ __ ] like I'm [ __ ] done
and
and to go on Ellen and to say I'm a
multi-millionaire I'm beloved I'm loved
by the world and I and I and I thought
about it let me get a hug let everybody
rally around me that's some weak ass
[ __ ] but you're mad that she did on
Ellen you're not mad that she felt that
way because you just said you felt that
no I'm mad because it's like how are you
so on how are you not self-aware like
I mean you travel you've been to these
Services you've been to these third
world [ __ ] countries you're talking
about people man they don't have running
water they don't have [ __ ] roofs like
they're there's girls getting raped by
their fathers as we speak getting
[ __ ] beat there's so much [ __ ] up
[ __ ] going on in the world and if you
look in the mirror and you can't
acknowledge how blessed you are like I
just I can't [ __ ] deal I get that I
can't even be around you stick to
another little break from chatting and
shoving food in our mouth with Sean
Strickland kids I know you've heard
about it by now that tiger thick sweet
nectar award-winning we're winning all
sorts of awards you see it online you
see it all over people like how can I
get it what are we doing here oh my God
what are we gonna do well guess what we
just restocked daddy that's right if you
go to thickboy.com right now you can
click on tiger thick you will see the
sweet nectar is in stock and available
be shipped straight to your door go to
thickboy.com click on tiger thick and it
will be shipped to your door that sweet
sweet award-winning nectar get on it
this episode of food truck dies with
Sean Strickland is also brought to you
by the best Kratom on planet Earth
that's right baby Kratom now a lot of
you guys are like man I'm I'm thinking
about trying to I don't know it's kind
of the Wild West out there it's like CBD
about six years ago and now cbd's
everywhere and you can trust some
companies well guess what
trust your thick friend here I take this
Kratom because the only Kratom I trust
those other brands I'm not sure can't
vouch for them but the one I can vouch
for that I use on every single show that
you watch me on and if you come to my
stand-up shows every single time I'm
using happy hippo Kratom that's right
it's the only brand I trust I take the
pink lemonade shot three to four times a
day some say I have a problem all good I
enjoy it helps me speak I need all the
help I can get if you want to use the
best focused product I've ever used and
guess what it's all natural that's right
it's all natural no gimmicks we got you
covered go to happyhippo herbals.com use
promo code sick boy for twin soft for
life you can share that with your aunt
your freaking gay sister whoever it is
Mom Dad Grandma Grandpa friends nephews
cousins your Myspace top five friends if
you're still doing that stuff your
grinder profile your Tinder profile
whatever you want use the promo code
thick boy for 20 soft for life all you
gotta do is go to happy hippo
herbals.com
promo code Stick Boy to himself for Life
use as many times as you want you're
welcome when you lost Pierre it didn't
cross my mind because you're such a
strong mental mentally dude it didn't
crush him I mean you're depressed like
you're depressed but in the day dude
you're like we're all gonna [ __ ] die
you know I remember like there's this
guy not the harp on Ronda Rousey just I
[ __ ] do not like her I I I you would
change your tune if you met her I'm sure
but here's the thing
you have similar piercing you're a nice
[ __ ] guy dude yeah you're a nice
[ __ ] guy and here's the problem with
nice [ __ ] guys whenever you meet
another nice person you don't want to be
like hey you're a [ __ ] because
you're a nice guy but like calling nice
people [ __ ] heads is one of the best
things ever like you know like you're
talking about
if they're a natural nice person there's
no reason to call them a [ __ ] it because
you're talking about the liver King I'm
talking about the liver King nice person
but he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] here's my
Finch on you don't know him but I do
know no you don't I know what he said
you know no you don't know no no no no
you know him as an [ __ ] from YouTube
no no no no that's like that's it's like
calling somebody that you don't know so
your your persona isn't no reflection of
you I could go and see what everyone
it's not a reflection of me what do you
mean so the hair is a liver King from
you're saying from his yeah so he's this
nice guy he he he's he pedals
supplements he lies he's probably on the
roids he talks about masculinity walking
on the shirt off that guy is an [ __ ]
he is no better than a [ __ ] woman but
we all highlight him because he has some
Fame we put him on a show but that man
is an [ __ ] and [ __ ] wait he's an
[ __ ] because he's just wrong he's
just a phony he's a fraud like he's just
he's a clown and like we all sit there
and like in 2022 the day of social media
and Tick Tock we're all like oh the
liver King let's let's put this [ __ ]
up on a pedestal that guy is no
different than a [ __ ] beta male woman
no [ __ ] different my only caveat with
that is so his his message is right is
to eat healthy live like the caveman do
so if he's promoting health I don't give
a [ __ ] how famous but again I will say
he does say a lot of good [ __ ] about
eating eating clean yeah I'll give that
so his main message is eating clean
living like the caveman did right I
don't give a [ __ ] if he's on stereo I
don't do I don't give a [ __ ] again it's
just like it's a gimmick dude it's the
[ __ ] gimmick like we live in a world
with [ __ ] gimmicks just be a normal
[ __ ] put a shirt on you do
[ __ ] steroids you're selling I just I
don't like
I don't like how we live in the social
media world
where you have people who are you know
Norm Macdonald did a great one
he talked about like an astronaut going
to the Moon he's like [ __ ] man like what
do I got to do to be famous
[ __ ] you're on the moon like
what do I got and we only know like one
or two of them went to the moon he's
like how do I [ __ ] top that now you
have 2022 [ __ ] like the Kardashians
and like well they're not good on them
they're actually barely even getting out
of them but more people know the
Kardashians and the [ __ ] that
land on the moon because we Buzz Aldrin
right yeah but old school but what I'm
saying though it's like we live in a
world where it's so easy to be famous
and the intellectual bar is going down
so much that if I want to be famous I
don't go and have an intelligent
conversation I act like a [ __ ] idiot
I go that's one way to get famous but
that's there's other billion fans from
being smart give me Tick Tock better
than Joe Rogan and you say tick tock I
mean but give me who else Jordan
Peterson Jordan
you you're naming three people who are
conservative icons most people no no I'm
saying whether they're left or right and
most people on the left who are smart
most people you go talk to most people
nobody's listening to Ben Shapiro and
and Jordan you have his his tax income
at the end of the month yeah but again
but again we're talking about like the
vast majority of like 18 year olds to 25
year olds
I don't know why I got on this [ __ ]
tangent at this point no I like but if
you oh yeah liver King why why you
should not be nice to [ __ ] like why
nice people why nice people you should
call them [ __ ] Serbian [ __ ]
because we live in a world where like
you know you could go back like
[ __ ] wear suits they would
dress nice they were talking away now if
you want to make money you want to be
famous you got to be an outlandish I
mean look at me first you got to be an
outlandish you gotta walk around their
shirt off you got to wear a rash guard
everywhere you [ __ ] go we just like
we just gotta go wrestling we just gotta
I mean that one [ __ ] weirdo we just
got talking about John Denver yeah John
[ __ ] is a smart dude man always a
[ __ ] again another [ __ ] weirdo I
wear a rash guard to a wedding because
it keeps me warm it's no you're a
[ __ ] weirdo and you want [ __ ]
attention and you're pandering you're
pandering to the 10th Planet [ __ ]
douchebags no he's not done playing well
but again you're all that Tim Planet
guys [ __ ] worship that [ __ ] guy
and I love people they worship Casey
I'll give you I'll give you a shout out
my boy Casey hasselstead in Vegas
[ __ ] guy's a killer if you're ever in
Vegas training with him Tim plan a guy
one of the best coaches ever but anyways
we talk about danaher John Donna Jan
John Donahue yes but he might be a smart
guy he is a smart guy because he comes
he comes from you Jiu Jitsu Fox and then
you he manipulates people like I wear a
rash guard I'm a [ __ ] weirdo and
everyone like he creates this quote like
[ __ ] following like we just but my
thing is world of clowns but why did he
create that cult like Fallen because
people are [ __ ] dumb it's not because
he's a talented the Box thinker but you
have these people like I mean who the
[ __ ] is John Denver he wrote a book on
Jiu Jitsu no he created a lot of the
moves that these guys use but again at
the end we live in a world of [ __ ]
clowns and that's one thing I'll say
about you dude you're not even Joe Rogan
you guys aren't a clown no but the breed
of of intellectual people is going down
I and I agree with you that and we are a
dying [ __ ] breed because like what we
have now like
it's a dying [ __ ] breed dude let me
ask this one who do you like
hi Joe Rogan
just Joe Rogan I mean
it's hard I'm sure he's done some stuff
to piss you off though uh I mean we all
do if you talk long enough yeah you're
not gonna be pleased with everything
anybody says 100 of the time the problem
is you're like I get along a lot with
like Russians and like a lot of these
like harder people
because you grew up hard brother well
yeah because I talk to these [ __ ]
people they're not clowns yeah they're
they're just they're just solid [ __ ]
guy and then you come to America and you
got to run to [ __ ] Rousey's no
offense here I know you like the girl
but like you got you got these [ __ ]
just soft brother I'm telling you know
let me tell you let me tell you Ronda
Rousey's a hard [ __ ] she's [ __ ]
strong no no I'll tell you Ronda Rousey
I mean she [ __ ] went in there and
like she [ __ ] people up as a fighter
Ronda Rousey deserves all the credit she
gets all the credit she gets
when I say soft that's not what I mean
soft tell me what I mean just like oh
it's not in the way she helped yeah you
think you think you take any you think
you take Alex Pereira any of these
[ __ ] Brazilians and you give them all
this [ __ ] money and they go get
knocked out they're gonna go on the L
and be like well I went back to my
country
um I I I uh I know running water no food
no electricity and I looked in the
mirror with all my millions and I
thought about killing myself [ __ ] no
they're gonna be like man I came from
[ __ ] nothing I can't even drink the
water in my country I'm a happy
[ __ ] and so what I mean that's
what I mean by Soft I get you and the
problem is too nothing we have that's
also her perspective right she has no
other perspective but again she didn't
grab enough perspective and this is
another thing like the modern generation
that I [ __ ] can't stand it's always
perspective like let me tell you Brendan
Shaw's perspective so you understand why
his views suck and you're like oh well I
I get that no [ __ ] you don't get
that just because you have a perspective
and I could somewhat relate to it
it doesn't mean it's right and and
that's the thing with like Rhonda's it
does though she grew up her document
suicide chew up I will tell you about my
dad I my dad was laying in bed one day
laying in bed with a 45. I [ __ ]
walked up he was talking about suicide
and I was like Dad you should [ __ ] do
it you know you should probably do it I
was like 17. I was like your wife left
you
you're unemployed you're a [ __ ] drug
addict your life sucks like you should
[ __ ] do I took the gun
said do it didn't [ __ ] do it died at
50 something of cancer and miserable
[ __ ] miserable and now you could all
look at that and be like Oh Sean you
advocated for suicide look I didn't
advocate for suicide I
I knew that he would have been better
off and he died miserable [ __ ] cancer
chemo he was so [ __ ] up on drugs you
by the time he forgot he had cancer like
it was everywhere yeah [ __ ] miserable
and this is the last thing I'm saying
that there's this guy solid guy holds
past the pi and he was telling me that
he OD'd and you know me being an [ __ ]
I'm like oh [ __ ] were you partying
you're trying to [ __ ] take a nap it's
like oh well he's a little bit of both
you know I told the story of my dad
I said let me tell you something
there's people like my dad
who you can give them a million dollars
a billion dollars and every day here
they're gonna wake up miserable
vindictive [ __ ] shady doesn't matter
what circumstance they're in they're a
miserable [ __ ] and that's why I gave my
dad the gun
and it was more of like putting a dog
down like like let me put him as misery
put you out of here I know that sounds
[ __ ] up
you know and I told about that my buddy
and I'm like listen I don't think you're
that [ __ ] guy you're a good guy yeah
you're a happy guy I see around here you
have a good personality I don't think
you're my dad yeah but if you are my dad
I'm gonna be the first [ __ ] hey
aim for the head and where was your mom
doing all this I [ __ ] stand somewhere
else okay yeah
I think a lot of your perspective and
it's gotten you pretty [ __ ] far
you're number seven in the world and you
win this next fight you fight for a
world title but don't you think a lot of
your perspective comes you grew up
[ __ ] rough dude that's why you relate
to these Russians but it's awesome but
again it's also going back to that you
you guys think that the Land of Plenty
lasts forever the land of what the Land
of Plenty you guys you guys think that
America lasts forever it doesn't you
look at you look at the economy you look
at where it's going like
yeah we're in some trouble we you the
the the softness of the world it's going
to reverb back the Land of Plenty
America is not going to last forever
agree and like you you [ __ ] soft
[ __ ] dude like you all will be
me enjoy it now give it three or four
generations five generations six
Generations it's gonna go back it's
gonna go back and then you know I'm just
a little bit a little bit too old for my
time yeah yeah you're you're an original
you're an outlier you're also what makes
you unique is like I know but a lot of
people also a lot of people like me
though because I'm a I I represent a lot
of people I represent a lot of people
where the dads got drunk beat the [ __ ]
out of them correct you know I represent
a lot still doing something positive
yeah I mean I mean if it wasn't for this
dude I would have [ __ ] probably
either been a serial killer but in jail
like yeah but you did you're doing this
number seven middleweight in the world
in the UFC which is tough to get to my
man yeah I know again
it is dude but yeah I just think a lot
of people kind of relate to me and like
my fan base they understand what it's
like to be like the like you know
especially being a white guy correct
like
you know you hear a lot of like and this
is my fan base you hear a lot of this
whole white privilege and now you come
to me like dude I was cutting the locks
off the water main yes like I didn't
have electricity sometimes yeah you grew
up rough so you you have like this white
jaded population they see me and they're
like yeah that's how I grew up dodging
beer cans like the water was shut off
like you know you go you go bounce a
check at this store then you know relate
to that let's take a little break last
break I know you're like oh my God were
these two gonna say this is getting
crazy don't worry we'll get right back
to the program but I gotta tell you
something about Alpha Brain from my
friends and on it Alpha Brain never
heard of it the best nootropic ever it's
everywhere if you haven't heard about it
are you living under a rock how about
this you've always heard about it and
you haven't tried it but you want to try
it well guess what I got you guys I got
everybody covered all you gotta do is go
to onnit.com and use uh it's on it.com
FTD for food truck diary right audit.com
FTD you save 10 off not only Alpha Brain
but all supplement moments all work out
gear at onit.com when you use the code
onnit.com FTD you get the best nootropic
on the freaking planet my boy Joe Rogan
says he uses it for every pod it helps
them form better sentences that's right
it would be more like Joe Rogan me too
and I'm hoping Alpha Brain gets me there
it's Up For Debate we'll see here's a
cool thing if you don't love it you get
your money back no return necessary all
you gotta do is give them about two
weeks you get your money back you have
nothing to lose here you've always
wanted to try out for brain now's your
time you can use the promo code onit.com
FTD or in your local Walmart
trying to help you out and not get you
to go to Walmart because it's a waste of
everybody's time right nobody wants to
go to Walmart and sit in line and look
at the trolls there we don't want to do
that so go to audit.com FTD save 10 off
the best nootropics on the planet from
on it on it.com FTD 10 off the entire on
it website what else you want from me
let's get back to the program
I mean I want you I've been a fan for a
while I mean I've stuck up for you for a
while I thought you're gonna beat Pierre
the reason I want you on the show is
because like this isn't manufactured
like what you're saying all this stuff
is of course I knew you're going to say
some wow well we all we all think but
it's not manufactured we all think it
what I say is something we all think
and do I do I put a little flavor on it
do I make it sound a landisher like I'm
not racist no I don't [ __ ] hate gays
I like [ __ ] bi women yeah you know I
I'm an equal opportunity person I think
I'm on this table but what I say a lot
of people agree with it and it might be
it might be off color it might be
awesome I mean you're paying a price for
it too because you know sponsorship's
gonna be tough to get it's just hard man
like don't me wrong dude if I knew if I
could tow the line and vote for Biden
and suck the dick like the rest of these
[ __ ] guys and you know [ __ ] Tim
with Izzy I mean doesn't Izzy have some
[ __ ] you know if I could do that if I
could paint my nails and be it would be
impossible for you it would be [ __ ]
impossible it would be [ __ ]
impossible for me but I'm not the knock
on Rhonda she's a good girl I like
Rhonda I don't think you're not gonna
dude again I know you don't like
perspective and you grew up a [ __ ]
tough life man tough tougher than most
it's not tougher than most dude like I
meant [ __ ] dude from what you
grew up with just it's all good dude but
here's it wasn't easy but the crazy
thing is though dude like I grew up like
my life compared to some [ __ ] I
know is [ __ ] Disneyland sure [ __ ]
Disneyland sure so it's like doesn't
matter though yeah but I just think that
dude that's why you're such like a
rugged hardcore dude yeah
but you've changed because you have
better perspective now
right
a better perspective don't turn that
[ __ ] on me I changed because you got
matured you grew up because I got out of
my environment and I got exposed to the
world that would be perspective Sean
[ __ ]
oh but you're you're
fires on me right now I'm just saying
dude that would be you gotta you got a
different well you can call it whatever
you want yeah we won't say perspective
the word perspective triggers you know
you know what is dude I had like I'll
tell you why I had a lot of people help
me as a child
and it wasn't the white principles it
wasn't the white teachers like a lot of
people who helped me like especially the
MMA Mexicans black guys yeah so you got
you know you take somebody who me I had
these deep racist thoughts from like a
kid to about 14. and you didn't know
better I didn't know about it yeah
you're angry dude you need something to
hate yep you know when you're angry and
if I don't know if you guys know this
you either hate someone or you hate
yourself correct and like that is a very
[ __ ] slippery path to putting a ball
in your head
so you know you you find something to
hate but man like
every white person I've ever met when I
was a kid and I would you know draw a
swash cut my arm they would be like [ __ ]
you we're gonna kick you out of school
we're gonna put you in a uh we're gonna
put you in a continuation school I had a
teacher once tell me
uh they built prisons for people like me
seventh grade uh [ __ ] misawaja [ __ ]
you miss wadja what's up now I've only
been in prison once [ __ ] you yeah wrong
is that wrong joke's on you yeah but you
know and then so then I go and Branch
out I go and Branch out and I actually
even felt some shame for this I would go
meet people of color or Mexicans and
they would like grew up in a shitty
neighborhood and you know I I started
realizing I have a lot in common with
you guys like me and you guys are the
same like you know the Mexicans like my
buddy David Gomez I David Gomez you
might be in jail for murder man I miss
you buddy I hit you up on Instagram
where the [ __ ] you at but uh you know
like
like uh I start realizing man me and you
guys are the same like me and you guys
are the same and then I was and then I
started really like looking at my
perspective like [ __ ] dude like I almost
don't like white people anymore is this
[ __ ] possible all the white people in
my life they [ __ ] [ __ ] on me they
kicked me out of [ __ ] school they
[ __ ] abuse me oh you know what I'm
saying all these things and all my
homies I'm like man so it's kind of like
this weird Awakening to me where I'm
started realizing like it even got to a
point to where I could almost swap we're
like I'm like you know [ __ ] you man yeah
like [ __ ] Mr Black [ __ ] you Mr white
guy you [ __ ] guy so then how how who
how did you get into your first MMA gym
so I knew this guy
um
I got kicked out of school
and I mean I was gonna do what grade
I think I dropped out at 10th grade okay
I got kicked out in ninth grade
uh
so dude I was just angry man I was
[ __ ] angry like you know people love
this whole like Jeffrey Dahmer thing and
I'm not trying to eat [ __ ] and
[ __ ] dudes yeah but I understand what
that's like to fantasize about something
and fixate on something to a point where
you start trying to act it out so when I
was younger I don't know dude I just I
fantasize on violence like I wanted to
[ __ ] kill somebody I wanted to
[ __ ] stab somebody
that's anger had it come from as a child
growing up yeah so I started like I
started fantasizing about it and putting
myself in situations so we're like you
know just like every other guy who
[ __ ] wants to kill somebody sure you
start fantasizing about it and you start
putting yourself in situations you start
thinking about it and you start going
through the [ __ ] motions of it which
I was doing when I'm talking about like
14 15 years old whether I'd be walking
in like a shitty area carrying a knife
or put a rock like just fantasize about
it
so I got into fighting because
it kind of scared me and you know I
thought I was like I [ __ ] you know
most people that want to hurt people
have low self-esteem correct you don't
really I mean unless you're like a
narcissistic psychopath most people that
enjoy violence and bringing pain to
people it's all low self-esteem yeah
they're hurting inside yeah so I always
stop fighting scared me and I hated it
so I joined a I went to a gym just
because like I didn't want us like a
[ __ ] and I [ __ ] loved it first time
I was ever happy all the anger went away
thank God yeah yeah man [ __ ] dude
I always tell people man if you guys
have PTSD I already said hey I used to
hate on vets with PTSD disgusting I'll
tell you why because you hear these
[ __ ] [ __ ] talk like no offense I
love soldiers yeah I don't give a [ __ ]
dude
let's go troops but no I'm full circle
you would hear these [ __ ] guys talk
and they're like yeah man like
it's hard for me to leave the house like
I'm in social situations I feel violent
and I'm shut down and I'm in my my thing
is like the [ __ ] wrong with you man
that just sounds like every day why
being a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah but you
didn't do five tours in Iraq but I'm
saying but here now full circle back to
the vets full circle back to the vets
and this is a perspective there you go
come on perspective man so perspective
once I realized that you're a normal
human being you go out with friends
you have family that you love you have
you go and drink you [ __ ] chase [ __ ]
you go to high school parties
to be that human being and then have the
veil drop
and they go from that to me
like I spent my entire life dealing with
learning how to cope and function and
after I made that realization that yeah
man that would be a really hard
[ __ ] thing so full circle if
you guys are vets out there and you
[ __ ] you know you want to Snuff out
your old lady or do some crazy [ __ ]
stuff out just [ __ ] go to join a gym
dude go to join a gym [ __ ] people up get
beat up man it takes the edge right off
you're in all this like to wrap this up
you're and I don't know how you're going
to take this you seems like it doesn't
take compliments well you're a success
story Sean [ __ ] a crazy success story
time time
will tell you guys that much money no
matter what happens don't even [ __ ]
never fight again your success story did
you if she's gonna contact me while Sean
you you insult the soul I know I didn't
insult you guys I'm saying I relate to
you mother though because I know what
it's like yeah you also insulted Ronda
Rousey like no I like it yeah you're
good Ben you're good no life is good
dude life's [ __ ] good and then you
[ __ ] die bro yep I'm with you you're
success story I don't know how you're
going to take that but hopefully you're
riding your motorcycle like maybe I
missed no I'm gonna [ __ ] I'm gonna
drive my motorcycle self-destructive
like I want to [ __ ] kill myself I'm
gonna look at my speedometer and it's
gonna go to like 105 and then traffic's
gonna [ __ ] stop going like it's just
five miles per hour and I'm gonna start
cranking it's gonna climb 115 125 and
it's gonna [ __ ] peek out you're a
wild [ __ ] and then I'm gonna see
someone like almost hit me and then like
my I'm gonna be like oh I almost [ __ ]
died I feel better life is good like
yeah life is [ __ ] good I feel better
now and there's certain things in your
life too this is what makes you one of
the reasons you're badass too you don't
drink after he's with you like I don't
drink
contrary belief I've never done drunk in
my life no and I don't think you I don't
yeah that's not even caffeine man I
thought maybe you drink but no you grew
up you know
but my father abusive alcoholic drank
you know got up pills later on
everything about him I hated yes
everything about him I hated
and then you combine my racist origins
of like you know more ethnic people do
drugs
then I became more of like
adamantly against it Adam Lee against
now I started training and I grew out of
all that now I can look back and like
yeah I shouldn't drink or do drugs yeah
it's probably not the best thing for me
no you do you've made another [ __ ]
slums your success story man I went
again you know but again I still I still
had a lot of like you know I
saw yourself short no no no no no no no
I mean yeah I like slept in jams if I
rode my back I shouldn't be here yeah
but again you know like I you know I let
my mom help me out you know my mom give
me I had more privilege than most more
privilege than most okay
you know if that makes you feel good
yeah you're a success story Sean I mean
[ __ ] I'm still not I still might lose my
[ __ ] mind one day so [ __ ] I'm
making a list you [ __ ] I'm just
joking you crossed me off that list come
on man I'm just joking that's only when
I go to bed night sometimes I lay bad
and I think oh man if everything goes to
[ __ ] everybody I'm sure everyone's
[ __ ] I mean what's [ __ ] let me get
you out of here I'll get you out here
man uh I will end on this out of uh some
just some fight picks Alex Pierre Izzy
who do you got I got Izzy Izzy's gonna
dance around [ __ ] run around fight
like a [ __ ] he's not gonna do what I do
he's not gonna stand in front of him I
think that's probably not smart I think
that's not smart
another interview saying that should be
the next dude I think that will be I'm
gonna fight is that I would rather watch
homozot versus Colby than uh Alex versus
Izzy I can agree with that that's a
[ __ ] fight because Kobe doesn't go
backwards yeah that's gonna be it's a
great fight
I mean as I know I know comma is not
spot a hard man with Gilbert but you
know it's a totally different animal
different animal American doing the damn
thing but again if he wins give him a
title belt shot I agree I'm sure if if
she might win just [ __ ] push him to a
title unless you want to give him a
cancel and make some more money yep and
then lastly wait wait wait wait I
thought he's going on 85 or 70. uh Hamza
yeah he so he put 85 but then he called
out Kobe so I think it's gonna be at 70.
yeah yeah uh last one Sean Strickland
Joe Towner how's that going down five
rounds and now when I found out it was
five rounds I've been telling stream
manager I'm like I love that it's five
rounds for you so you guys are fine so I
believe I've never watched Jared can air
fight I don't find that I believe
I think about this [ __ ] too much I'm
obsess about it where it's like when I'm
not I don't like you know we're not in
full-blown camps and actually kind of
funny to um kind of funny uh I watch one
fight Alex
that's why I watch fights and he was
fighting uh Bruno Silva okay and if you
look at Bruno Silva what was he Landing
the straight cross yeah straight cross
so you thought straight cross be scared
of the straight cross if you notice
everything down the pipe my hands
weren't needed to be yep but what it
wasn't for was it punched his his money
maker so I try not to get too fixated on
guys because I stopped I stopped just
being myself and I start like trying to
do what they do yeah he stopped reacting
that's what I mean he's a [ __ ] scary
[ __ ] dude used to be heavyweight
yeah he's a heavy [ __ ] it hits
hard I mean who [ __ ] knows I could
get knocked the [ __ ] out I could win who
[ __ ] knows if I if I knew I'd be
making a [ __ ] ton of money betting it's
gonna be a good fight though but depends
on the odds I still want to make a ton
of money
I've never been in my life no and if you
win you get a towel shot man I'm excited
for everyone show for a while now I
don't know how you can get them on the
motorcycle everyone come to the show we
give shoes regardless I know you're not
super sneaker head here but Sneakerhead
Bros out the kids they say these days
the sneaker head I don't think no it's
uh that's that's more of like the older
crowd Club is it your brand issue or
what no no no no I don't have my own
shoe I'm not there yet but they might be
more comfortable on your motorcycle so
these are we have to do it no matter
what I know you're not a big snake head
doesn't matter these are the rules of
food truck these are for you they're
some dope shoes so these from my boys
says Mr Strickland please wear enjoy
these pada uh yeah Pata Air Max we know
you'll love uh beating the crap out of
people and these seem like the perfect
murdered out pair for you they're all
black who the [ __ ] is uh uh suplex it's
a store in uh Philly who gives me shoes
for the fighters so they pick them out
these are for you
these are expensive shoes so if you
don't like I'll tell you what
I'm not a big fan of free [ __ ] I don't
like being on things but man I
appreciate that and I don't think I'll
ever wear these but thanks boss that
works brother appreciate you coming on
Sean Strickland everybody thank you
brother
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're into thick boys
like subscribe comment
and God bless America oh that's not my
big one just kidding